The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's start.
So for several
lectures, we've been
talking about the
XY model, which
is a collection of
two component spins,
for example defined
on a square lattice,
but it could be any
type of lattice.
And today we are going
to compare and contrast
that with the case of a solid.
More specifically for
simplicity, an isotropic solid.
And a typical example of
an isotropic solid in two
dimension is the
triangular lattice.
So something like this.
What both of these
systems have in common
is that there is an underlying
continuous symmetry that
is broken.
In the case of the XY
model, at low temperatures
all of the spins would
be pointing more or less
in the same direction.
Potentially with
fluctuations, let's say, go
around the direction
where they're
supposed to be
pointing-- being, let's
say, here in the
vertical-- characterized
by some kind of an angle.
Let's call it theta.
And essentially the uniform
state at 0 temperature
can be characterized
by any theta.
And because of the
deformations, it's
captured through these low
energy Goldstone modes.
And the probability of
some particular deformation
will be proportional at low
temperature to the integral,
let's say, in d
dimensions of gradient,
the change in theta within
different spins squared.
Of course, with some
considerations as
we discussed about topological
defects, et cetera,
being buried in
this description.
Now, similarly, away
from 0 temperature
the atoms of a solid
will fluctuate around
the position that
corresponds to the minimum.
And so the actual
picture that you
would see at any
finite temperature
would be distorted with respect
to the perfect configuration
and there would be some kind
of a vector [INAUDIBLE] u
at each location that would
describe this fluctuation.
Again, there is no cost in
making a uniform distortion
theta that is the
same across space.
And similarly here,
there is no cost
in uniformly translating things.
So these would both imply that
this row can [? continue ?]
[INAUDIBLE] leads
to Goldstone modes.
And the corresponding
energy cost
in the case of the
isotropically distorted system
is typically returned
as an integral involving
elastic moduli, as we've seen.
And the traditional
way to write that
is in this form where
the same reason here
that it wasn't theta
that was appearing
but gradient of theta,
because a uniform theta
does not make any cross.
These strain fields are related
derivatives of the distortion.
But now we remember
that this u is a vector
and this strain field uij it
was one half of the derivative
of uj in the i direction
derivative of ui
in the j direction symmetrized.
Actually, probably better
to write this symmetrically
as beta h equals
to this quantity.
And then the typical
type of calculation
that we did for the
XY model was to go
in terms of the independent
spin wave modes.
So we go to Fourier space.
This becomes an integral
ddq 2 pi to the d.
The derivative here
gave q squared.
And then I had something like
the Fourier transformed theta
squared.
Now I can also more
clearly represent
this in the Fourier description.
I will get something like 1/2
integral vdq 2 pi to the d.
And a little bit of work
shows that this form Fourier
transforms to something
that is proportional to mu.
Again, it has to be
proportionality to q squared
because the energy
should go to 0
as q goes to 0 for very
long wavelength modes.
And so we'll have something
like q squared mu tilde of q
squared.
This is a vector squared.
u is a vector.
q is a vector.
And there is another component
that gives you mu plus lambda.
And consistent with
rotational symmetry,
we can have a term that is
q dotted with u tilde of q,
the whole thing squared.
And again, you can
reason that you
can describe the isotropic
system in terms of just two
elastic moduli is that the
only rotational invariant
quantities are q squared,
u squared, and q.u,
that those are the only terms
that you can [? find. ?]
Now the next thing.
Once you know this form, you
can immediately say something
about the fluctuations.
So you say that expectation
value of theta tilde q theta
tilde q prime, if I assume
that this is a Gaussian theory
and these are the
only fluctuations
that I'm considering,
the answer is
going to be 2 pi to the d
delta function q plus q prime.
And then I will get a
factor of 1 over kq squared.
The corresponding thing here
is a bit more complicated.
Because as we said, this
quantity u tilde is a vector.
And I can look at the
correlation between, say,
the i-th component of
that vector along mode
q, the j-th component of
that vector along mu 2 prime
and ask what this is.
And again, only the
same values of q
are coupled together, so we get
the usual formula over here.
If this term was the only
term in the story, that
is if we were dealing
with vectors q and u that
are orthogonal to
each other, then we
would just get the
1 over q squared.
And so there is actually
a term that is like that.
But because of this other
term, there is the possibility
that q and u are in the same
direction, in which case,
these two costs
will add up and I
will get something that
is proportional to 2
mu plus lambda.
And so then I will get 2
mu plus lambda q squared.
And here I will have qi qj.
This becomes q to the 4th.
Let me make sure that I did
not write this incorrectly.
Yes, I did write it incorrectly.
It turns out that there is a
mu plus lambda out here too.
But essentially there's
just a small complication
that we get because of the
fact that you have a vector u.
But overall the
scaling is something
that goes like 1 over q squared,
which is characteristics
of Goldstone modes here with
additional vectorial things
to worry about.
Let me make sure I
separate these two.
Now one of the things that
we have been concerned with
is whether these fluctuations
destroy long range order, so
for long range order the
information that we would like
to have is that the
entirety of the system
is roughly pointing
in the same direction,
meaning that if I know
that this beam here
is pointed in the
vertical direction,
if I go very far away,
it is still more or less
pointed out-- pointing
in the same direction.
So for that, we could
look, for example,
as the degree which
[? with ?] these two spins?
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
q squared [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: This is 4.
Is that what you're
worried about?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It should be 2, I guess.
PROFESSOR: No, because I have
two powers of q out front.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: So I
think in the notes
what I have is that
I have actually
written things this way.
I put the factor of mu
q squared out front.
And then I had this
as qi qj over q.
And I think--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
q squared [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: q squared.
Let me one more time check to
make sure that that's not--
actually there's a minus sign.
All right.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't there
be another factor of mu
to compensate for
the factoring out?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So let's check this in
the following fashion.
So I can look at modes
where u and q are
perpendicular to each other.
When u and q are
perpendicular to each other,
I don't have this there.
And so then what I should
have is just a cost
that is 1 over mu q squared.
OK.
So let's see if
that comes about.
What I can do is
let's say imagine
that I'm looking at a q that is
oriented along the x direction.
And I look at u's that
are in the y direction.
And I correlate two
u's in the y direction.
So I will definitely
get a delta ij here.
I would have a 1.
Here I would get a
factor of nothing,
because this term is absent.
The q's that I'm
looking at don't
have any component along the
direction of u that I'm having.
So this is absent
and I will get a 1
over mu q squared, which
is consistent with that.
Now let's look at the case
where I look at u's that
are aligned with the vector q.
Let's say again in
the x direction.
Then, as far as the
energy is concerned,
both terms are
present and the cost
should be 2 mu plus lambda.
So the answer that I
should ultimately get
should be 1 over
2 mu plus lambda.
So let's check.
So here q squared-- and
cancels with this q squared.
All of the q's are in the
direction of the indices
that I'm looking at.
So that cancels.
This is 1.
So I will get 1 minus mu plus
lambda over 2 mu plus lambda.
So then I will get 2 mu plus
lambda minus mu minus lambda.
So I will get a mu in
front that cancels this.
And I will be left with
just the 2 mu plus lambda.
So we've checked
that this is correct.
All right.
So this is a proof, if
you like, by induction.
You knew that the only
forms that are consistent
are delta ij and qi
qj over q squared.
So we can give them two
coefficients, a and b,
and then adjust a and b so
that these two limits that I
considered are reproduced.
So-- OK.
I didn't have to
resort to my notes
if I was willing to spend
the corresponding three
minutes here.
So going back here, in order
to see the degree of alignment
of the two spins that we have
over here, what we need to do
is to do is to look something
like cosine of, say,
theta at location x
minus theta at location x
prime, which is non
other than the real part
of the expectation value of
e to the theta at location
x minus theta at
location x prime.
And assuming that everything is
governed by this Gaussian rate,
the answer is going to obtain
by computing this Gaussian
as exponential of
minus 1/2 the average
of theta x minus
theta x prime squared.
So then my task is
to replace theta x
and theta x prime in terms of
these theta tilde in Fourier
space.
And then this will give
me some expectation
that involves this average.
And when I complete
that, eventually I
need to Fourier transform
1 over q squared.
And we've seen that the Fourier
transform of the 1 over q
squared is the
Coulomb interaction.
And so ultimately this becomes
exponential of minus of 1
over k.
The Coulomb interaction
as a function
of x minus x prime with
the appropriate cutoff
included in this expression.
And then the statement
that we always make
is that this entity
at large distances,
the Coulomb interaction saying
three dimension, falls off as 1
over separation.
So in three dimensions,
this at large distances
goes to a constant 1
over k is something that
is proportional to temperature.
So after doing
enough temperature,
this entity at large
distances goes to a constant.
So there is some knowledge
about the correlation
between these
things that is left.
Whereas in two
dimensions and below,
when I go to sufficiently
large distances
the Coulomb
interaction diverges.
This whole thing goes to
0 and information is lost.
So this is the in content
that Goldstone modes
destroy through long range order
in two dimensions and below.
Except that we saw
that in two dimensions,
because the Coulomb interaction
grows logarithmically,
this correlation
fall off according
to this description only as
a power law with an exponent
connected to k.
And then the discussion
that we had for the XY model
was that at high
temperatures you
have exponential decay
in two dimensions.
At low temperature you
have power law decay.
Although there is no
true long range order,
there has to be a
phase transition.
And we saw that
this transition was
described by the unbinding
of these topological defects.
So we would like to state
that something similar to that
is going on over here.
The only reason I
went through this
was to figure out what
the analog of this entity
should be in the
case of the solid.
So the analog of our theta is
this vector u, the distortion.
What should be the analog
of e to the i theta?
And the things that you should
keep in mind is that theta,
I can't really tell
it's difference
between theta and theta plus 2
pi, theta of 4 pi, et cetera.
So this e to the i
theta captures that.
If theta goes to theta
plus a multiple of 2 pi, e
to the i theta
remains invariant.
So it's a good
measure of ordering.
It's better than theta itself.
So similarly, there's
a better measure
of deviation from
perfect order here
for the case of the lattice.
You say, well, why
should I worry about
that since I can measure what
u is from the perfect position?
Well, my answer is
this point here.
Did it come from
here or from there?
Should you use for u this
or should you use that?
You don't know.
So the u that you have the
to use similar to the theta
that you're using is
somewhat arbitrary.
And the arbitrariness of
it is given by unit vectors
along the original lattice.
That is, u and any u that
is increased or decreased
by some lattice vector
of the original lattice
is the same thing.
You can't take them apart
in the same sense that theta
and multiple of 2 pi you cannot.
So then that suggest that I can
construct some kind of an order
parameter, I call it row
G, which is like this.
This e to i something.
It's e to the iu
but u is a vector.
And what I do I multiple by a
G, which is an inverse lattice
vector.
So G is an inverse
lattice vector.
And essentially the
inverse lattice vectors
are defined to have the property
that when you multiply them
with any of the original lattice
vectors-- which are, let's say,
parametrized by two
integers, m and n--
the answer is going to
be some multiple of 2 pi.
So you can see that
irrespective of whether I choose
u as distortion from one lattice
position or any other lattice
position that
happens to be nearby,
this measure is going to be
giving you the same face.
So in the same way as
before for the spins where
I asked whether spins
at large distances
are correlated long range,
I can do the same thing here
and define a long range
correlations for a solid
by looking at e to the iG dotted
with, let's say, u at position
x minus u at position x prime.
And x and x prime are two
points on the lattice.
And again, the u's that I
have are Gaussian distributed.
So this I will
complete the square.
I will have
exponential minus 1/2.
Well, OK, let me be a little
bit careful with this.
I have G alpha G
beta over 2 because I
have two factors of G dot u.
I will write them using
Einstein's summation convention
as G alpha times u alpha
component times the u beta
component.
So once more what we
can do is to then write
these u's in terms of
their Fourier vectors.
So what I will have is
exponential minus G alpha G
beta over 2.
I will need to
integrate over q's.
Because of these
factors, I will get
something like 2 minus 2
cosine of qx minus x prime.
So whenever you go to Fourier
space, you will get e to the iq
x minus e to the iq x prime.
Different one for
here with different q
primes, but when you
take the average,
q prime is set to
minus q so then you
get this form as usual.
And then I will have the average
Fourier transform use, which
is what I wrote over there.
I will get a 1 over mu q square
delta i delta alpha beta minus
q alpha q beta q squared mu
plus lambda over mu plus lambda.
There is a little
bit of subtlety here.
So I will do something
this is not quite kosher
but gives me the right answer.
Certainly I can take this
G alpha a beta inside here.
When it multiplies
delta alpha beta,
I will simply get G squared.
I really G alpha G alpha.
Sum over alpha.
It will give me G squared.
Here what I will
get is a G dot q
squared because I will have
two Gq's divided by q squared.
Ultimately I have to integrate
over all values of q, including
all angle values.
So there will be, as far
as the angle is concerned,
something like a
cosine squared here.
And the rather
unconventional thing to do
is to angular
averages that first
and write this as
G squared over 2.
Once you do that,
then essentially
you can see that this structure
just gives you a constant.
And what you will need to
do is the usual Fourier
transformation of
1 over q squared.
So eventually you can
see that the answer
is going to be proportional
to minus G squared.
I will get a factor
of 2 mu u from here.
Once I have written this
as G squared over 2,
I will get 1 minus
1/2 of this quantity.
So that becomes 2
mu plus lambda--
or 4 mu plus lambda
minus mu minus lambda.
So I will get a 3 mu plus lambda
divided by 2 2 mu plus lambda.
And so there's a
factor of 4 here.
So that's just the numerics
that goes out front.
The key to the whole thing will
be the usual integration of 1
over q squared.
Just as we had before, I will
get again the same Coulomb
interaction as a
function of x minus x
prime with appropriate
lattice cut-off
introduced so that
the short distance
behavior is controlled.
This whole thing has a name.
It's called a
Debye-Waller factor.
Well, almost.
In 3D.
And the point is
that if I'm looking
at this whole thing
in three dimensions,
at large enough separation
this will go to a constant,
just as we had before.
And I will conclude
that this entity, as I
look at two points that are
very far apart, at least that's
sufficiently low temperature
and all of my mus and lambdas
are scaled inversely
with temperature,
so this whole thing is
proportional to temperature.
Essentially, you can see
that this information
at large distance goes
to a finite constant,
telling me that there's
long range orders preserved.
Again, when I go
to two dimensions,
you would say that this,
at large distances,
grows logarithmically.
And so the correlations
will fall off,
but fall of as a power law.
Now for the case
of a solid, usually
what you do in order to
probe for the order is
you shine x-rays and
you see what comes out.
So essentially, you
will see that there
will be some scattering.
And the way that the wave
vector of the light has changed
is characterized by a vector q.
And we discussed this already,
that the structure factor
s of q is going to be related to
expectation value of the phase
that you get from
the different points.
So I will get a factor
of e to the i q.
the location of the different
atoms, let's call them r, of x.
I have to do a sum over x.
I have to scatter
from all of the atoms.
There's some overall form
factor that if I'm not
really interested,
but this whole thing
has to be first squished.
So once I square this, I
will be getting averages
between pairs of points.
Because of
translational symmetry
I can relate to that
sum over pairs of points
to a center of
mass that typically
would pick up the number
of points that I have.
And then the
expectation value of e
to the something like
sum over all points, e
to the i q.r r of x
minus r of 0 average.
This average I can
certainly take out here.
Yes?
STUDENT: Sorry.
Is r what you're
calling u before?
PROFESSOR: No.
So r is the actual location of
where the particle is location.
So r, let's say for a particle
that at zero temperature
was sitting at lattice
point-- that is,
let's say, in two dimensions
labeled by m and n--
it is shifted by an
amount that is u that I
would assign to that point.
So the r's that I put here are
the actual physical position
of the atom.
Which is composed
of where it was
sitting at 0 temperature
plus a little bit more.
So when I do this, indeed I will
get a sum over all positions.
This could be a label mn,
whatever, of e to the iq.
The difference
between the two r's
would be, first of all, the
difference between these two
at 0 temperature, which
would be some lattice
vector of some variety.
Let's call r 0 of x.
And that quantity has
[INAUDIBLE] fluctuations.
The fluctuations go into e to
the iq.u of x minus mu of 0.
Now if I'm doing this at 0
temperature or very close to 0
temperature where this is either
1 at 0 temperature or not too
much fluctuating at
high temperatures,
I will essentially be
adding a lot of e to iqr's.
These are essentially phases.
They can be positive, negative,
all over the complex plane.
And typically you would expect
that for a randomly chosen q,
the answer from adding all
of these things will be 0.
So the only time we're
close to 0 temperature,
you expect this to be
something that is significant.
Scattering is when q is one of
these inverse lattice vectors.
So if I was really doing this at
0 temperature, this would be 1.
And the answer that I
would get is essentially
I would get these delta
function back peaks
at the locations that correspond
to the inverse lattice spacing.
And that's presuming
something that you have seen
in crystallography or whatever.
You take a solid and you
scatter light from it
and you will back points.
So what I expect
is that when I have
a q that is roughly close to
G but not necessarily sitting
exactly at that point,
what I would get
is a scattering that these
proportional to an integral
over the entire
lattice of something
like how far I am away
from the right position.
And I should really write this
as a sum over lattice points,
but I can approximate
this by an integral.
The integral again has the
property that it will give me 0
unless q is exactly
sitting at G.
And then for here, I
evaluate this quantity
when q is close to
G according to what
I have calculated up there.
So I will get
exponential of minus G
squared-- What do I have?
Over 4 mu, three mu plus
lambda, 2 mu plus lambda.
The Coulomb interaction
as a function of x.
Yes?
STUDENT: Are you missing
an overall factor of m?
PROFESSOR: That's why I
wrote the proportionality.
Because what I'm really
interested is what you see.
And what you see is how things
are varying as a function of q.
So I'll tell you
what the answer is.
So you do the Fourier
transform from this.
And in d equals to 3, what
you find at 0 temperature,
as we said, you
will get Bragg spots
at the locations of
G's that correspond
to the inverse lattice vectors,
which actually themselves
form a lattice.
So this is essentially
the space of q.
And these are the
different values of G.
Now what happens is that
the strength of each one
of these delta functions
is then modulated
by this factor evaluated
at the corresponding G.
And since it is
proportional to G squared,
you find that the spots
that are close to the origin
are well defined.
As you go further and further
away, the become very weaker.
And at some point you
cease to see them.
So that's the-- the
Debye-Waller factor
describes how these
things vanish as you
go further and further away.
And essentially, you find
that they go and diminish
as e to the minus G squared.
But clearly, this kind of
scattering from a crystal
is very different
from the scattering
that you expect from
an liquid, which
is essentially you will have
a bright spot at q close to 0
and things that would
symmetrically fall off,
maybe with a couple
of oscillations
due to the size of the
particles, at cetera.
Now what happens in d equals
to 2 is kind of interesting.
Because in d equals
to 2, I'm doing a two
dimensional integral,
and this thing
is growing as a power law.
So basically what
I end up having
to deal with is something
like e to the i q minus G x.
And something that falls off
as a over x to some power
that I will simply cause eta G.
So related to that combination.
And when you
integrate this, just
dimensionally you
can see that it
is an integral that scales as
x to the power of 2 minus eta.
x is inverse to q minus G. So
this is going to scale as 1
over q minus g to the
power of 2 minus eta.
So as you go along some
particular direction
and ask what you see,
you find that will
see peaks close to the locations
of the lattice vectors.
So let's say they are equally
spaced along the particular
axis that I'm picking.
In three dimension, you would
have been seeing delta function
at each one of these positions
whose strength is governed
by this Debye-Waller factor.
In two dimensions,
you will essentially
see power laws close
to each one of them.
But as you go further, the
exponent of the power law
changes.
So at some point you even
cease to have a divergence.
But you can essentially
ignore anything
like that [? happening. ?]
So you can see that because
we don't have true long range
order into two
dimensions because
of these logarithmic
divergences,
et cetera, the
traditional picture
that we have of a solid that
is characterized by Bragg
scattering and delta
function peaks is modified,
but still it is
something that looks
very different from the liquid.
So we expect that as
we raise temperature
there is a phase transition
between scattering
of this form and something
that looks like liquid.
And you can roughly
guess that essentially it
is going to be related
with these etas becoming
larger and larger so that
these divergences disappear.
But what is the mechanism?
So let's go back and see what
the mechanism was that we
discovered for the XY model.
So we are going to look at
d equals to 2 from now on.
That discussion so
far was general.
In d equals to 2, we said that
we have topological defect.
And the story here was that,
as I have been discussing,
the angle is
undefined up to 2 pi.
So it would configuration of
angles that kind of radiate
away from the origin.
And the idea was that
if I take a circuit
and integrate around
this circuit--
let's call this the s gradient
of theta-- the answer does not
need to come back to 0.
It will be some
multiple of 2 pi .
Some integer multiple.
And similarly here, we
said that the value of u
is undefined up to
a lattice spacing.
That leads to topological
defects, which
I find it very difficult to
draw for the triangular lattice,
so I'll draw it for
the square lattice.
So at each one of
these positions
there's a particle sitting.
And you look out here.
You have a perfect
square lattice.
You look out here.
You have a perfect
square lattice.
But clearly it is not a
perfect square lattice.
And the analog of the
circuit that I drew over here
that encloses a
singlularty-- there's clearly
some kind of a defect
sitting over here--
is that I can start with
some point on the lattice
and perform what is
called a Burgers Circuit.
What Burgers Circuit
is is some walk
that you would take
on a lattice, which
in a perfect lattice
would bring you back
to your starting point.
So for example-- that was
not a good starting point.
Let me start from here.
Let's say I take four steps
up-- one, two, three, four.
I take five steps to the right.
One, two, three, four, five.
I reverse my four steps.
So I go four steps down.
One, two, three, four.
I reverse my five steps
and I go five steps left.
One, two, three, four, five.
And you see that I did
not end up where I was.
I ended up here.
And a failure to
close my circuit
has to be a lattice vector.
And this is called d and
it's called a Burgers Vector
that characterize this defect,
which is called a dislocation.
So the uncertainty that I have
in assigning a value for u
because of being on a lattice
or deforming a lattice
gives rise to these
kinds of ambiguity
that are similar to
the topological defects
that you had over here.
Whereas the defects here were
characterized by an integer,
the defects here
are characterized
by a lattice vector.
And here the simplest things
were, say, plus or minus.
Clearly here on
the square lattice
the simplest things are plus b,
minus b along the x direction
and plus b minus b
along the y direction.
For example, on the
triangular lattice
it would be plus minus at
any of the three directions
that would define the lattice.
So calculating the distortion
field here was actually
an easy matter because we said
that the gradient of theta
was something like 1 over r.
And so the gradient of
theta, which was 1 over r,
I could in fact write--
we saw as vector
that is orthogonal to the vector
that is going out of the plane.
So we call that a z hat.
It was also orthogonal to
the direction of motion
away from the defect,
which we could characterize
by looking at the gradient.
The gradient vector
for this distortion
is clearly in the
radial direction.
And the answer that we
had here for one defect
was ni log of r minus ri.
And since I'm taking the
gradient it doesn't matter.
I can't put or not
put the cut off.
And if I had multiple ones,
I would simply sum over it.
So this was the contribution
to the distortion
that came from a collection
of defects such as this.
Now you can see that essentially
in some continuum sense,
all I'm doing here is similar.
I can be taking a big circuit.
And as I go along
that big circuit,
I can take a gradient--
So let's-- yeah.
The s.
gradient of the
distortion field.
Distortion field is,
of course, a vector.
So it has components that I
can write as the x component
or the y component.
So this alpha could be the x
component of the distortion
or the y component
of the distortion.
And once I complete the circuit,
here the answer was 2 pi n.
Here the answer is
a lattice vector,
which is this Burgers Vector
that could be in any direction
that you want.
Now as far as
mathematics is concerned,
this line and this line for each
component are exactly the same.
So the solution that I can
write for gradient of u
I can just copy from
here for each component.
So I can write that
gradient of the u that
is due to a collection
of dislocations
is something like z
hat crossed with curl
of a sum over all of
the potential locations
off my defect.
Rather than n, I have b over 2.
And it's a vector log of
minus ri over [INAUDIBLE].
So if I have a collection
of these dislocations
at different places on my
lattice-- locations ri,
strengths, b alpha
which is a vector--
then the distortion field
that they would generate
is given by this.
It's very just following the
answers that the [INAUDIBLE].
So then what we did for the
case of the overall system--
in order to find how the
different topological defects
interact with each
was to calculate
beta h, which was an integral
of gradient of theta squared.
Yes?
STUDENT: So the b alpha, you
have an index i [? also? ?]
PROFESSOR: b alpha
have index i also.
Like like the ni have index i.
So maybe I write
it in this fashion.
Yeah.
So this is the cost that
we have to evaluate,
except that we
have to be somewhat
careful with the meaning
of this gradient of theta
in that the gradient
of theta, as we said,
has a contribution that
is from regular spin
waves, the Goldstone modes,
that can be deformed back
to everybody pointing
in the same direction
without topological defect.
Plus a contribution due to this
topological defect that are
categorized in that case by ni.
Now similarly here for
the case of the solid,
we have the beta h.
Slightly more complicated
integral d 2x.
We have mu uij uij plus
lambda over 2 uii ujj.
And what we can do is to
say that our strain field
uij has a component that
is like the Goldstone modes
that we have been
calculating so far,
essentially treating
everything as Gaussians.
Except that I will
write it as phi ij.
And then a part that would come
from the distortion field u
bar that I calculated.
So I take that distortion field
and then take derivatives of it
to symmetrize
appropriately to construct
the strain that sums from them.
So we substituted
this form over here.
And we found that beta h that we
got had a part that was simply
relate to the Goldstone modes.
This was the part that could
be treating as a Gaussian.
And then we had a
part that corresponded
to the interactions
among these defects.
And that part we saw
had the character
of charges ni and
nj plus minus 1
characterizing these
topological defects
having a Coulomb interaction
[? between them ?].
And then, of course,
this i less than j,
we had to worry about what
was happening when i was j.
And that we considered
to be the contributions
of the core energy that,
once exponentiated,
we described as y.
So it's beta h which is log
of that would be log of y.
And actually this k bar, by
the way, was simply 2 pi k.
And it was 2 pi k because each
one of these charges is 2 pi n.
So there's 2 pi 2 pi.
But the Coulomb
interaction really
should be log divided by 2 pi.
And so k bar becomes
2 pi k times this.
So I can do the same
thing over here.
And what I find happens is
that my beta h gets decomposed
as follows.
There will be a part that is
simply the original expression
now for the field
that is well behaved
and has no dislocation piece.
And then you
wouldn't be surprised
because this structure
is no different
from the other structure.
There's essentially a
gradient of this distortion
field squared.
And you can see that if I
take a second derivative
of this distortion field or one
derivative of this, effectively
I will have two
derivatives of a log, which
will give me a delta function.
So essentially these
things do behave
like what you would get from
Coulomb type of potential.
[INAUDIBLE] plus [INAUDIBLE]
if the potential is 0.
So not surprisingly, I
we get a minus k bar sum
over pairs of where these
dislocations are located.
And then I will have b at
location i, b at location j.
And then I would have a log of
ri minus rj with some cut off.
Except that these b's
are actually vector.
So this term is a dot
product of the two b's.
And it turns out that when
you go through the algebra,
there is another
term, which is bi.
ri minus rj, bj dotted
with ri minus rj
divided by ri minus rj squared.
So the charges that we
had in our original theory
were scalar quantities.
These defects were characterized
by a scalar value of n.
And they were interacting
with something
that was like the ordinary
Coulomb potential.
Whereas now we are
looking at a system
that is characterized by
charges that are vectors.
And it turns out that
what we have here
is the vectorial analog
of the Coulomb potential.
And again, if you think about
an isotropic system and vectors,
this is a vector
that you can form,
but b.r is another
vector that you can form.
And so both of them do appear.
And once you go through
the whole algebra
and through the inverse
Fourier transform, et cetera,
you get this
additional contribution
to this vector
Coulomb interaction.
That's really is
the only difference.
And of course,
you will again get
a sum over all locations
of the core energies
for creating these defects.
And the value of k bar here
is related to these parameters
by mu mu plus lambda divided
by pi 2u plus lambda.
So this combination
controls what you have.
So the next thing
that we did was
to construct a perturbation.
We essentially said that if
I have these pairs of charges
that can spontaneously
appear at an energy
cost but an entropy gain,
they will effectively weaken
the overall Coulomb potential.
For example, if I
have to test charges
then there will be
some polarization
of the medium,
some reorientation
of these charges that
appear, that weakens
the effective charge here.
And we could
perturbatively calculate
what the correction
was, except that we
found that that
correction, which
involves an integration over
the separation of these things.
There was an integration
that was potentially
divergent for us no matter
how small we made the core
energies here.
And so what we did was
eventually to construct an RG.
And the RG was that the
value of this parameter k
bar-- actually more
usefully its inverse that
is related to
temperature-- changed
as a function of integrating
out short distance
degrees of freedom.
It was something like 4 pi--
I think it was 4 pi cubed,
it doesn't matter-- y squared.
And that the scaling
of to core energy
itself was determined
by 2 minus pi k,
which in terms of this k
bar becomes 2 minus k bar
over 2 times y.
And we can do exactly
the same thing over here,
except for the
complication of having
to deal with the charges
that are vectorial.
And you get that the strength
of the Coulomb interaction,
it's inverse that is
related temperature
gets re-normalized by
exactly the same process.
That is, there will be
charges that will appear.
All the mathematics you
can see is clearly similar.
And there will be a
reduction, which then you
can think of as an increase
in temperature, which will
be proportional to y squared.
I don't know what the constant
of proportionality is.
And that dy by dl--
so essentially I
focus on the simplest
type of dislocations
that I would have
of unit spacing--
has exactly the
same [INAUDIBLE],
2 minus k bar over 2 y.
It turns out that there
is actually a difference.
And the difference
is as follows.
That while we did not
calculate the next correction
in this series, I said
that this correction came
from essentially what
would a single dipole do,
which would be some contribution
that is order of y squared.
And I expect that there
will be correction
if I look at a configuration
that has pairs of dipoles.
And this will change
this by order of y
to the fourth and this
by order of y cubed.
Whereas if I look at something
like a triangular lattice,
you can see that if I have
two dislocations out there
as test dislocations
pointing out
in opposite
directions, which would
have some kind of a
interaction such as this.
And I ask how that
interaction is
modified by the presence
of dipoles of dislocation
in the medium.
I could put a pair
of dislocations
integrate over the
separation between them.
I will get, essentially,
the same type
of mathematical structure that
would ultimately give me this.
But then the next order
term in this series
is not for
dislocations because I
can have a neutral configuration
of three dislocations,
such as this.
And so once you
do that, you will
find that the next
correction here
is order of y cubed and
order of y squared here.
But generically, both of
them have a phase diagram
for RG flows that involves
the inverse of the interaction
of these charges.
That is a
temperature-like quantity.
And there is a critical value
of that inverse, which is 1/4.
And what happens is that--
let's see, this other axis is y.
Anything smaller than
1/4 y tends to go to 0.
Anything larger, y
tends to get larger.
And there is going to be
some kind of a separatrix
that he describes the transition
between flows that go down here
and the flows that go away.
And presumably, as I heat up my
original system-- my lattice,
different types of lattices--
at low temperature,
I can figure out what this
combination of mu an lambda is.
That gives me some value of k.
And there is some kind of the
core energy for the vertices
that I can calculate.
So there will be some point
in this phase diagram, which
at low enough temperature I will
go over here, which corresponds
to a system that has an
effective logarithmic
interaction between
dislocations.
As I change the temperature,
I will proceed around
some trajectory such as this
because everything will change.
And presumably, at some
point I will intersect this
and I will go to
the other phase.
Now the characteristic
of the other phase
was that this parameter
k was going to 0.
It was essentially the
logarithmic interaction
was disappeared.
And you can see that that
parameter k going to 0
means that mu, the shear
modulus, has to go to 0.
So basically this phase out
here is definitely characterized
by 0 shear modulus.
So again, the two
parameters mu and lambda, mu
is the one that
gives you the cost
of trying to shear in a system.
And essentially the presence
of the resistance to shear
is what defines a solid for you.
So this is a solid to something
that does not have rigidity
transition.
It turns out that there
is one subtlety here.
I don't know whether it's
good to mention or not.
But so in the case of alpha
this superfluidity, for example,
we said that this
coupling strength as you
approach the transition
rose to a universal value.
In these units it will be 4.
But that it approaches
that universal value
with a logarithmic singularity.
Sorry, with a square
root singularly.
Sorry.
And we saw that this was
experimentally observed
in films of superfluid film.
I also said that
on the other side
you have a finite correlations.
The correlations will be
decaying exponentially.
And this correlation length has
this very unusual signature,
which is that it diverged as
a square root of t minus tc
in the exponent.
It was giving rise to these
essentially singularities.
While everything kind of looks
identical between this RG
and the other RG, it
turns out that once you
keep track of these corrections,
these corrections actually
are important.
And for the vectorial
version of the Coulomb gas,
you find that they shear modulus
that is finite in this phase
reaches its final
value, which is not
universal because the
thing that the universal is
that combination that
involves both mu and lambda.
But rather than stc
minus t to the 1/2,
stc minus t to
some exponent that
is called mu bar, which
is 0.36963 [INAUDIBLE].
So this is a kind
of subtle thing
that is buried in these
recursion relationships
once you go to a higher order.
And accompanying that is
a correlation length that
also diverges with some behavior
dominated by the same exponent.
So once people understood
the original [? Koster ?]
[INAUDIBLE]
transition, it was kind
of a very natural
next step for them
to think about these
locations in a two dimensional
solid and say that
in the same manner
that the unbinding
of these defects
got rid of the residual
long range order that
was left in the XY model.
That this kind of
ordering that we said
exists for the two
dimensional solid,
this appears as a result of
unbinding of dislocations
and you get a liquid.
Turns out that
that's not correct.
And it was pointed
out by Bert Halperin
I think that if you
look at a solid,
there's two things that you.
You have the
translational order,
but there's also
orientational order.
That is, you can
look, for example,
at a collection of
spins here and the bonds
are pointing along
the x and y directions
and you can look down here
and the bonds are pointing
in the x and y directions.
And from the picture
that I drew over here,
you can kind of see that once
I insert this dislocation which
corresponds to an
additional line,
the positions here
are distorted.
Once I have many
of these inserted,
it is kind of
obvious that I will
lose any idea of how the
position of this lattice point
and something out
there is related.
It's not so obvious
that inserting
lots and lots of
these lines will
remove the knowledge
that I have about
the orientation of the bonds.
And the insight that
we will follow up--
and maybe it's probably a
good idea to do it next time--
is that actually once
the dislocations unbind,
we will lose this
kind of ordering.
If I do this in two
dimensions, these
are power law decays
at low temperatures.
Once the dislocations
unbind, this
becomes an exponential
decay, as I would expect.
But I can also define locally
some kind of an orientation.
Let's again call it theta.
But theta is, let's say, the
orientation of the bond that
connects two neighboring spins.
Now what I can do is to look at
the correlation of orientations
at different positions.
And it turns out that
if I'm doing something
like a triangular lattice,
I can't just pick the angle
and correlate the angle from
one point to another point
because let's say on the square
lattice the angle itself,
I don't know whether
it was coming
from a bond that was
originally in the x direction
or in the y direction.
So this is unknown up to
a factor of 90 degrees.
In the triangular lattice
it is an unknown up
to a factor of 60 degrees.
So what I should do is I should
define e to the 6 i theta
at each location as a measure
of the orientational order.
You can see that, again,
if I'm at 0 temperature,
I can reorient the lattice
any way that I like.
This phase would be the same
across the entire system.
So what I'm interested
is to find out
what is the expectation
value of this object when
I look at points that
are further apart.
And again, clearly if
I'm at 0 temperature
these thetas are the same.
This will go to 1 at
finite temperature.
Because of the fluctuations
it will start to move a bit.
And what we can show-- and
you will do it next time--
is that as long as you are
in the 0 temperature phase
you will find that this
goes to a constant,
even in two dimensions.
But once the dislocations
unbind, what we will show
is that it doesn't
decay exponentially,
but then it starts to decay
as 1 over x to some power,
let's call it eta theta.
And then at some
higher temperatures,
it eventually starts
to decay exponentially.
So there is the
original solid in two
dimension that we started
that has true long range
order in the orientations.
And that is reflected
in these Fourier
transforms that we make.
So we said that when we do
the Fourier transform and look
at the x-ray scattering,
let's say from a two
dimensional crystal, you were
seeing these kinds of pictures.
And then these were
becoming weaker
as we went further
and further out.
But now you can see that
this picture clearly
has a very, very defined
orientational aspect to it.
Now once we go to this
intermediate phase,
all of these peaks disappear.
But what you find is that
when you look at this, rather
than getting a ring
that is uniform,
you will a see a ring that has
very well- defined variation.
One, two, three,
four, five, six.
Six-fold symmetry to it.
So this phase has no
knowledge of where
the particles are located,
but knows the orientations.
It's a kind of a liquid crystal.
It actually has a name.
It's called hexatic.
But it's one of the family of
different types of materials
that have no translational
order but some kind
of orientational order
that are hexatics.
So the transition between
this hexatic phase
to this fully disordered phase,
it turns out in two dimension
to be another one of
these dislocation--
well, topology defect
unbinding transition.
So maybe we will finish
with that next time around.